Justin Bieber gets a haircut explains
why he was crying in public Demi Lovato
cancels her tour and Grant Gustin is not
here for you body shamers guys it
finally happened I literally said weeks
ago Justin Bieber needs to chop off that
mop and he did well kind of JB's fiance
Haley Baldwin looked on as her future
groom got in a little pre-wedding
grooming at her go to Soho hair salon
Cutler the stylist revealed Biebs only
got a trim because he wanted to keep it
long the engaged couple looked pretty
happy with the cut which is a far cry
for what looked like a distraught Justin
just the day before Bieber was snapped
hiding his face while breaking down in
public yesterday with his fiance of for
weeks
Haley's head it was in her hand and
seemed to be comforting her man but
could it be cold feet here's what Bieber
had to say for himself about the
emotional outburst this what is that
Timothy Keller
you got good days you got bad days ain't
that's the truth but did you see the
book Biebs is holding it's the meaning
of marriage facing the complexities of
commitment with the wisdom of God
basically provides tips on how to have a
successful marriage now if that doesn't
tell you how serious justin is about
marrying Haley while I chatted with
Justin and Haley's close friends singer
Madison beard just yesterday and she
says Justin's never been happier I'm
just happy that he's so healthy and he's
doing so well right now and like it just
makes me so happy to see him well
because I've known him for so many years
and I just know his heart and I know how
good of a person he is I saw that you
congratulated he and Haley on the
engagement called in your family members
I mean you're gonna go to the wedding um
yeah I guess I think so that the
invitations have been set out yet but
I'm assuming I've actually known Haley
long as I'm happy which is funny but
yeah they're both I'm just so happy that
they're happy together because I think
that he really needs her and she seems
like the real deal huh yeah absolutely
like they've they've always been they've
always had such a weird chemistry of
like everyone kind of always knew they
were gonna end up together so it okay
they were to ship this one folks
meanwhile a source tells ET Bieber's ex
Selena wants nothing but happiness for
that so hopefully this is the last time
I bring her up when I talk about Biebs
but no
quote me on that alright you guys
already know but Justin and Selena ended
things for good in March the real
question is now is Selena ready to date
we're told she still doesn't feel ready
and while she would love to be in a
relationship in the future she is much
more cautious now our source also says
she's incredibly focused on her career
the 26 year olds latest project is the
fashion line coach excellent Gomez it's
her second collaboration with the brand
I mean while it looks like fans of
Selena's old pal Demi Lovato will have
to wait awhile to see her in concert
again
Live Nation revealed that Demi has
canceled the rest of her tell me you
love me tour in South America to focus
on her recovery a source told et on
Monday that the senior inner rehab for
further treatment after spending nearly
two weeks at cedars-sinai Medical Center
in Los Angeles
and finally the flash-start Grant Gustin
has had it with body shamers and
rightfully so this week a photo of Grant
in his unfinished season 5 flash costume
leaked online and some fans jumped in to
complain not only about the look of the
suit but how grant looked inside of in
he got pissed I'm not gonna read his
entire post on Instagram because it is
pretty lengthy but he said he was
unaware of the photo being taken there
adjusting the suit he's mad about the
leak but what he's really mad about are
the comments about his appearance quote
I've had 20 plus years of kids and
adults telling me or my parents I was
too thin I've had my own journey of
accepting it I'm happy with my body and
who I am and other kids who are built
like me and thinner than me should be
able to feel the same way not only that
but they should be able to feel like
they could be a superhero on TV and to
that I say you have better preach grant
I know some people thought this was a
tiny thing that he shouldn't have been
bothered by but I gotta agree with him
that there is a double standard when it
comes to guys bodies and from someone
who had a few extra pounds on him for
most of his life and then lost it now
I'm told I'm too skinny and over the top
of that thanks grant for speaking your
truth right you guys are amazing just
the way
and with that mini Bruno cover I'll see
you guys tomorrow for new music Friday